más del 98% de la energía que costa
rica- consume desde hace 7 años proviene
de fuentes renovables el sistema
eléctrico garantiza un servicio sin
apagones que pongan en riesgo las
labores de grandes industrias como esta
productora de lácteos que opera 24 horas
al día los 7 días de la semana y que
anualmente requiere de unos 47 millones
de kilovatios/hora para todos sus
procesos los temas de energía limpia
reducción de impactos ambientales
preocupación con el medio ambiente y por
la sociedad no es una cuestión solamente
altruista no es solamente una cuestión
de buenos sentimientos tiene que ver con
disminuir los riesgos de operación de
las empresas el país se liberó del uso
de los hidrocarburos gracias a una
decisión tomada hace más de 70 años de
transformar su matriz eléctrica pero
además lo ha hecho venciendo el reto que
supone lidiar con el carácter
impredecible de la naturaleza cuando no
hasta el viento cuando no está el sol o
cuando no llueve entonces no tenemos
disponibilidad
sin embargo tenemos también los embalses
que hemos construido tenemos también la
capacidad de almacenar en esos embalses
que nos permiten regular los períodos en
los cuales no hay este recurso los 5
millones de habitantes también se
benefician de electricidad limpia en su
vida diaria pero hay quienes piensan que
es momento de asumir el siguiente reto
ambiental en términos de electricidad y
evidentemente hemos dado pasos
importantes como país sin embargo en
términos de transporte y de uso de
hidrocarburos para el para los vehículos
estamos bastante lejos estamos bastante
atrasados terminar de descarbonizar su
economía hacia el año 2050 es la
ambiciosa meta que costa rica- predica
hoy de cara a la crisis climática que
afecta al planeta